hello good people have you to my name's
Dave Rubin I am the new as host here at
The Young Turks network-based
is the Reuben report my name's rubin it
work
he was nice he was mayor Ruben Studdard
he works cheaper
yet they still won with me pretty good
how we got a great show for you were
going to be doing here
on the Reuben report is hot topics
things that you know about things that
maybe you don't know about with a group
of people that
again maybe you know maybe you don't
know but I know that you should know
them
think about that we gotta have a great
group 3
fine people with us today marcellous
how r year do and not mom and Marky Mark
on Twitter and very good work on that no
complaints you had no complaints
everyone knows that I am a very very
bitter person who commits
about every day but and lead a blessed
life alright
better but no complaint good start
nagging
not yet Jackie monahan comedian
and funny lady your raconteur
I would call you thank you are you doing
yeah I'm explants
yeah life is treating you very good as
well a blast
and why he wriggles as to I don't know
I'm yeah I'm getting there yeah I'm
getting there it's Dave Holmes
I'm and who has one of my favorite at
Twitter BIOS the guy from this thing
back Bing know the other things are
sometimes they got nothing in general
you mean we go from the face of maybe
yeah
and maybe maybe not I get off who knows
who knows you been her to be here
well I'm gradually rose on the New shell
thank you guys for come in and I'm
thrilled to be doing this with you guys
and what we're gonna be doing
as I said it's hot topics were gonna be
choppin em up distributing them
throughout the week and we're going to
start with what was the big story
last week of course involving a glass of
water
and a man with a very dry mouth of
course i'm talking about.
Marco Rubio giving the rebuttal to
Obama's state in the Union Address let's
take a look
nothing has frustrated me more
than false choices like the one the
president laid out tonight the choices
and just between the government and big
business
what we need is an accountable efficient
and effective government
that allow small new businesses to
create more middle-class jobs
alright so that was the Sweetwater heard
round-the-world
guys everyone's all over this on Twitter
social media everywhere
what's your take Marcel issue for really
good product placement for Poland
Springs
unfortunately they said it may be gone
within the little girls
you know thought so movie out the Obama
girls
all that they should have just been
standing there now they say to put the
bottle and they hands because I me at
the end of the day
who cares about like some white guy with
the kids yeah they're they're better
spokes model is all around
absolutely yeah so this was a diz Marco
Rubio not fit with Poland Springs this
bat where the product placement issue is
here man I i think on spring doesn't
wanna be associated with panic
know anything I can say is that could
add to that that is the content every
panic attack I've ever had I always am
afraid that I'm just gonna
you know I'm gonna have a dry mouth I'm
just gonna like breakdown on live
television
that dude it in France one the biggest
audiences in the world
Jackie you're a well seasoned performer
nothing ever breaks you what what do you
make I've
a dry mouth politician that's right you
coming on saint yeah
I believe you to use of liquid his child
middle-class champ away
I yeah he looks crazy doesn't he looks
insane
and I like I couldn't take my eyes off
that has not taking his eyes at the
camera
yes can I got quien es I was mesmerized
how much as you think was that it was
that kind of steve is that he has to
keep looking at the camera the whole
time get we're all watching him
yeah going menu ni a drink like how much
do you think just the
awkwardness of having to talk to the
camera itself the whole time played into
this
I can't believe there isn't like a pill
that he could have taken or spray that
would have stopped that dry mouth
Italian government number correct code
you know how I'm very glad to go in
person you're out there is right around
and we some like think that burst in our
mouths at yeah
what I think that I thought was
interesting in the fallout from this
thing
watergate as they work like that was at
CNN actually I think it's a good idea
make that one
unfortunately I CNN actually put a car
on that said
career ender with question mark could
this be a career ender
and is that like the point that we're at
this point where you just you can't
to rate you may get a little parched and
next thing you know your career
this is the young star of the
republicans I i mean I guess
you know we could talk Howard Dean about
that who was you know who is that
presumptive
nominee of the Democratic Party few
years ago and then he made a weird noise
with his mouth
yeah and I was a joke you know it's
rhamat now I think things are a little
bit accelerated I think it's you know we
go through means very quickly he was
quick to make fun events
and I think I think that is being at can
we yeah I swear that was just those this
wheel
I this is my marketing a soft kiss at
work
but I but its its we we go through them
so fast and I think people jumped I'm so
quickly that his supporters are sorted
gonna
have his back you know i mean it's a
like it's not fair for CNN and same as
evidenced by STC and mobily career ender
is probably the only Republican under a
hundred he sort of good looking this is
like their big hole
if watergate if his undoing well so they
can I like some down our throats and who
else is there there's no you know about
hormones that Western oh well
Jackie last not I think if Britney
Spears can come back from flashing her
vagina
like this guy I'll be okay yeah cars as
they
umbrella yeah you know the bomber about
it I is that the it distracted from the
content of the speech which was sort of
hateful and not a whole lot of new ideas
we can talk about that lol
I thought it was the ultimate
distraction because the speech had
absolutely no
content anyway so it's like all let me
water yeah he's really fun no one's
gonna notice
ya seem like he was like they were going
to notice that yeah and that is the
funny stiff part love politics that we
all see all the time but he kept looking
at the camera and yet leaving in in such
a way like no one's gonna see what I how
to do a hand